- So a father brought his young son
into an elephant enclosure
in the San Diego Zoo.
Clearly this is incredible illegal.
The video is haunting,
and it's amazing that no one got hurt.
(elephant grunting)
But the man was arrested.
And of course, people have asked,
what is he going to be charged with?
Well, the obvious things here
are probably criminal trespass.
Just because you have permission
to be in the San Diego
Zoo generally doesn't mean
you can go into the elephant enclosure
or the lion enclosure.
Then of course there is the child neglect
and child endangerment.
Here, this is manifestly reckless conduct.
This is the kind of thing
that you don't want any parent ever doing.
And it's definitely not worth the selfies
to endanger your child.
And this is exactly the kind of thing
that the authorities are
going to take a hard look at,
because the father was being
incredibly, incredibly stupid.
So don't be like this father
and don't endanger your child,
or I will see you in court.